okay it's time to draft for the
divisional round the eight remaining
quarterbacks are confidence in them it
gets more difficult this time because
there are some very good quarterbacks
playing this weekend here's the trivia
question to determine the first pick
chris there will be five heisman trophy
winners on the rosters for the titans
ravens game
name them
okay well derek henry
uh marcus mariota
mark ingram
rg3 lamar jackson
wow
what color is blue wait you got it
there's the horn that was it no horn for
sims no they played the music you just
can't hear it you're in a garage in west
virginia okay but i heard
my first pick is
i'm going with patrick mahomes that's my
number one pick this is not an easy
number one pick this week like you said
but i have the most confidence in him
one because listen i'll continue to
argue it's not all about any one of
these guys we gotta stop all this damn
quarterback crap is the only reason a
team wins and loses well then why why
are we doing this directly i don't know
i don't produce the show it's your show
get bringing it in all right
but i will say mahomes i do have
tremendous confidence in him i mean
first off i think he's the best
quarterback in football at this point
he's played in a lot of big football
games he's never seems phased in fact he
just makes biggest plays in the biggest
moments it doesn't matter and then i
take into account of course the talent
around him and andy reid's record and
track record with a bye week all those
things just make me think man mahomes
this kansas city team their offense
they're going to come out firing on all
cylinders and i have the most confidence
in him to come through whether the
offense is clicking or not i think
that's why i pick him one even if it's
not cooking i have confidence he will
make the plays to make it look like it's
clicking for all of us
and it is amazing when you think about
how the chiefs entered the season as a
super bowl contender short list chiefs
patriots afc championship game that's
what we all expected and then mahomes
got injured the chiefs hit some
adversity lost some games at home and we
just kind of forgot about that i still
feel like there's kind of there's still
this weird sense yeah they're under the
radar they're the only team from the
final eight last year that is back in
and i agree with you patrick mahomes is
the guy who has the playoff experience
almost got to the super bowl last year
and i think that that positive outcome
of last year even though they didn't
make it to the super bowl yeah it's not
like it was his fault in overtime he
never got on the field so i agree with
you with the selection of patrick
mahomes but but the mvp this year and it
should be unanimous and it won't be
because the all-pro selection wasn't
unanimous lamar jackson baltimore ravens
just because of the fact that he is the
most phenomenal overall
athletic quarterback running and passing
led the league in touchdown passes 1200
rushing yards rested and ready to go
and even though he got a taste of the
playoffs last year and lost i think
things are different this year i don't
think last year's game really counts
because i think lamar jackson and with
the assistance of greg roman the ravens
offensive coordinator i think he's found
a higher level of performance than what
we ever saw last year and i think that
he is physically unstoppable i'm not
worried about the fact that he lost last
year if anything i think that's going to
make him more motivated i agree having
to get it right yeah this time around so
and it's not going to be easy i i think
you know i'm starting to think kristin i
don't know which one i'm starting to
think one of these six seats is going to
win on saturday either minnesota or
tennessee i think the titans are going
to give them everything they can handle
but i think that's going to prompt lamar
jackson to find an even higher level of
performance yeah well i mean go ahead
pick them when we do our pix podcast
later today and be airing tomorrow eight
a uh seven and eight am pick it make it
happen okay big boy uh but i hear you
with lamar jackson and i agree with you
that you know last year is only going to
help the playoff experience the loss all
that and this ravens team is just is his
leaps and bounds better than last year
and the offense is more complex too they
have more answers and more wrinkles and
little things to do and he's more of an
effective passer than he was last year
too so uh lamar jackson fresh legs two
weeks off he might have three rockets up
his butt this weekend i mean he's gonna
be flying around i can't wait to watch
him all right this is where it gets
tough
damn it's tough but i go with though oh
aaron
rodgers
wait wait
challenge flag
because last week he was like your i
think i grabbed him around three or four
how are you grabbing him in round two
i'm reassessing okay i'm reassessing for
a number of reasons i mean because he
played so well last weekend well i you
know what i didn't love what i saw from
desean watson and that offense that
scares me a little bit
i don't have a lot of faith in seattle's
offense other than russell just making
big taking big shots i'm not sure about
their run game one thing i know is aaron
rodgers in green bay is usually really
damn good and really tough to beat and
the one thing i do know is for
what i call the greatest quarterback
ever
and he's a gunslinger nobody takes care
of the ball better than aaron rodgers
he's got the greatest touchdown
interception ratio in the history of the
league he had the best one again this
year he is phenomenal that way and that
does help me trust him and of course
he's playing against seattle and it's
not a great secondary as we know
and green bay can can can protect the
passer so i i look at that and go man
it's tough between rogers watson wilson
i get it but i think i trust aaron
rodgers more than any of them just a
smidgen more than than russell wilson
smidgen smidgen midge or smidgen
i don't know i got to look that one up
look it up rhymes all i know is it
rhymes with pigeon all right russell
wilson is going to be my next pick
because of the and we did this yesterday
peter king and i did it with coaches i
look for those super bowl rings i'm
going to err on the side of that past
performance and we've seen it from aaron
rodgers we've seen it from russell
wilson yeah he won the super bowl six
years ago was back there and but for
that one unfortunate play call at the
end of the game could have had two in a
row so russell wilson the guy who makes
the offense go in seattle be interesting
to see what kind of defense mike patton
dials up by packers you chastise jim
schwartz for not taking away the pass
and forcing the seahawks to run but this
week marshawn lynch another week better
prepared to be in football shape maybe
if you do take away the pass marshawn
lynch lights you up and then you adjust
to that and then the passing opportunity
is there either way russell wilson's
ability to avoid pressure spin out of
trouble make things happen extend the
play get rid of the ball or just flat
out run it i got a ton of confidence in
russell wilson yeah i mean come on i
mean it just yeah of course he's it's
he's amazing and you know what you're
right about marshawn lynch but if i'm
green bay and mike pettin i'm i'm still
doing it going
no i'm gonna protect my corners i'm
playing past defense
show me that marshawn lynch is ready to
play football that way show me that
seahawks run game is ready to get off
the ground and really start dominating
once again i would call their bluff if
i'm the green bay packers so that'll be
interesting to see but yeah russell's
awesome i'm going to go with the sean
watson yep he's the next one i mean come
on when you talk about these matchups
watson versus mahomes wilson versus
rogers holy cow is that amazing i mean
that just alone is really great but
desean watson
you know last week again i have
confidence in deshaun watson because if
the team around him the offense is not
working the defense has a great game
plan you know like mahomes right now
it's like okay great but does that mean
you're gonna stop desean watson i don't
know if it does oh you know hey we got
home free on a blitz oh i don't know if
it matters he might break the tackle and
throw a 50-yard pass i mean he's just
phenomenal that way and
a superstar and it's really cool to see
this this new era of young quarterbacks
kind of making their first playoff runs
and establishing you know their their
legend status a little bit here early in
their careers
so it comes down to this oh baby
[Applause]
[Music]
or is it jimmy garoppolo right and look
ryan tannehill you're going to be the
last kid picked in the playground today
because you only threw the ball 15 times
last week so if your coach doesn't have
confidence in you we don't either in the
post season right
baltimore or it's cousins right and let
me tell you let me tell you here's
here's the bottom line yeah
we saw two great throws from kirk
cousins in overtime i didn't like his
demeanor on the sidelines the final
drive of the game here goes
psychoanalysis here we go
all i can do is make conclusions based
on what i see
go ahead and and in the first half it
did it wasn't great and i just i just i
think the vikings are trying to will
kirk cousins to a higher level of
performance even though jimmy garoppolo
has never played a playoff game
he has played playoff type moments this
year the two games against seattle the
game against baltimore the game against
new orleans and to me that outweighs two
throws made by kirk cousins in overtime
against the saints so i'm going with
jimmy garoppolo i get it i mean jimmy
garoppolo you know i i think has
answered all the questions this year
plus to the point we talk about he's got
a great offensive coordinator and talent
around him and all that and he really
you know hasn't hasn't been phased by
any big moment really all year long you
know and i i get that i think jimmy
garoppolo will
take off right where he left off after
that seattle game with a hot hand and
and then we're going another round here
right
uh yeah let's do it after the break
you like that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports